john you got to spend time here
absolutely yeah now is it correct do we
need to apologize
were we not that welcoming to you no no
most people are so
welcoming um customs agents not so much
i'm sure customs is a pain for everybody
right it's a little bit of like i got
somewhere to be
no you guys love it they live here it's
quite easy
you just walk around i'm in the line of
no i went up to when she was shooting i
was shooting something in montreal so i
flew back
to see the kids and and my wife um and
uh i remember going through customs
everything was fine and and then one
week
just got unlucky and there was a guy
about my age seemed a bit grumpy
and he said um let me see he said yeah
he said uh
you're an actor and i said yeah he goes
what do i know you from i said
i don't know if you'd know i mean we did
the american version of your british
office
strike one yeah
i love that show the uk version i get it
i get it and then he said who are you
visiting i sent my wife and he said is
she an actress and i said yeah
he said would i know her i said i don't
know and he said what's her name and i
said emily blunt as he was writing
something and he went
you
you yeah and he goes all right get out
of here
like stamped my passport with a fury
john also i i did encourage him that he
would be welcome more if he stopped
wearing a baseball cap because i just
said you look so american
nobody has baseball caps oh that makes
it better you look so american
i just wanted you to blend in it's just
called prejudice is what
he went out and bought himself a tweed
flat cap
no he looked awesome was that good no we
don't like something i have a guy
ritchie film you look great
and he walked down the street and it was
like the sun came out because suddenly a
guy turned him and he went
all right what what does that say about
your country that it's like well if you
lose the baseball hat
just wear a tweed that's what it says
what do you need
it's that simple then and was it nice
because you're presumably having your
children spending time here with white
ice yes because
are they american children you said it
kind of sneering neither oh it doesn't
happen weirder yeah
put your cap on you'll be fine you're
like dry heaved you're like are they
american
[Music]
[Applause]
it's worse than the film and then an
american came out of here
i mean they are semi-american
they do become um quite uh well my
oldest daughter became quite british
sounding over the course of the year
that i was here for mary poppins and she
was sort of saying things like bath and
water
and now she's back to water
you have now learned how to do the
voices from towie
yeah sort of yeah well i we love that
possible
we love that garbage tv back in
in the states my wife was crazy about it
when i was
here filming guardians we shot guardians
of the galaxy here in
in london and and my wife anna came out
to visit
and she fell in love with this show
towie the only way is essex it's this
show that's like basically their jersey
shorts the jersey shore from
right from here it's like this uh town
somewhere
essex i guess and
these folks are just like the worst and
it was like i'm a parrot a little bit
and so when i hear
when i hear it all the time i just
started picking it up and started like i
could pick up their accent and do their
accent a little bit
yeah i'm okay this is going to sound
this is really embarrassing to do in
front of a
whole room full of brits here but i'll
try it anyways so it's like
so like honestly i saw this guy
because he's telling me he's like you
know i miss you or whatever
[Applause]
that will never be useful that would be
useful but that's very good now i want
to watch the show
i love the fact that you spent months in
england
and that's what you talk about so tom
do you want to start you do you do one
question one to him and one
i don't think i am i don't know nicole
if they don't know the answers i'll
throw to you
sure don't ask me
question number one okay what did
captain kirk
call mr spock in the spores
infection episode that forced him to
blow his
top and put his fist through the
enterprise console
as he was trying to beat his captain to
a pulp
oh was it was it something like
you like it's something half breed right
it's
is it so close so close so close
worthless that was the first part
then he called him jojo the dog-faced
boy
no you remember that i'll be in the cage
right next to
jojo the dog face boy
you knew that right was the ear guy
okay here we go here we go next question
okay harry mudd
returned in a sequel to his first season
episode muds women
what was that episode called i am harry
mudd
thinking about it that was a season
three mod sister so he
he probably came back again
would have been his second appearance so
technically are we giving the boys
[Applause]
the rest of their lives nicole would you
go get us a couple of dinner time
this lady came up to us we had a bbc
party she came up to the tour we were
chatting
sharing our wine straws and uh she went
i do disability at the bbc
whatever that means and then she looked
at him
and what did she say to you well she
said that i qualify
it was a hype thing
[Applause]
since we had that meeting when the lady
told me that i was
technically as far as the bbc is
concerned disabled
i had a member of a i won't know where
tell me
that i could get a parking badge
the rest of the couch is so jealous
right now
parking pads
i won't forget the day that ryan gosling
high fives makers
because i'm officially disabled
so i'm real for you no there's part of
that where i thought i'm not sure this
could happen
i don't i don't get it really well i
wish i could but i can't
believe that it would it's not very
unlikely to happen isn't it
i watch the avengers i go wow never
going to happen
how can i say this isn't rich coming
from you because didn't you
didn't you write for a children's comic
i i did yeah i
oh suddenly oh avengers no i don't think
so
which is more realistic the avengers or
dora the explorer
because that's what he wrote dorian
explorer i used to write for dora the
explorer magazine yeah i don't want to
don't want to brag but
now i've i've got a copy said that's
great
he's an actor and he couldn't deliver
that line
[Laughter]
that was incredible that was sincerity
now we've got we've got an issue of the
magazine that uh josh contributed to
no it wasn't contributed to i wrote the
whole thing mate
you wrote this whole magazine can i say
it's only six pages
i think it took like a day
there's a nice poem in it i wrote the
poem yeah yeah silly steps
it's about how to do a funny dance yes
and
can i just say before you read it out
this isn't my finest work
this issue this issue this job really
so stretch and pull your mouth and why
to make a silly grin
squid your face between your hands go on
squish it in
rhymes now this is the bit where i think
dora really would dora sing this
stick your bottom out behind you and
wiggle it wiggle it to and fro
could i just say this was a different
time
now make your favorite silly face and do
the silliest down to you
no yeah i think it rhymes it scans
it's lovely it works and you know what
else it was a job
yes yeah is this for kids though
no no it played big in the 20 to 30 year
i've seen you do a thing and i like
you're on a suit but can you do it
the the deadlift thing
she needs some space
no no no no no oh oh wow
[Applause]
but let me tell you something december
26th of the master square garden won't
be so gentle
[Applause]
[Music]
so emmerstone had to finger me
uh in order to sort of avoid finding
anything that you shouldn't have about
because it's sort of under the sheets
like that and she said i'm a little bit
worried about it don't worry don't worry
um
we'll uh i know i know so i asked makeup
taught if they had a sponge
and so i put a sponge there i said there
was a balloon
it was a big wet sponge so
you made up this story afterwards her
face was a picture
she's going up my leg and she went
[Laughter]
joffrey cersei in payne
the mountain eric dondarrion
soros of mir the red woman
tom hanks anthony joshua
yay
[Applause]
please kill me
you